sommes en direct avec valérie boyer
députée les républicains des bouches du
rhône bonsoir déry aboyer merci d'être
avec nous on le rappelle vous avez été
testée positive en coronavirus vous
suivez actuellement justement le
traitement expérimental à la chloroquine
du professeur round
première question déjà comment vous
sentez-vous et comment se passe ce
traitement
un traitement qui est très simple puis
donc fait trois prix de cachets par jour
matin midi et soir
donc la fée de le matin amélie a le soir
donc que plaqué n'y est plus voilà donc
je suis pas ton depuis le 17 mars
ce matin je suis allé à l'ap-hm un
quinté sur house pour faire un suivi on
voir où j'en étais ma charge virale qui
peut dîner et je vais me la prendre et
j'ai rendez vous vendredi pour continuer
le suivi donc au mieux sur l'état de
santé clairement alors le haut conseil
de santé publique vous l'avez entendu
recommande de ne pas utiliser ce
traitement à la chloroquine sauf pour
des formes graves
quelle est votre réaction vous moi j'ai
une réaction de malades
je ne peux pas me prononcer là dessus je
lundi dernier j'avais sainte anne ont
donc me suis rendu comme tout le monde à
l'infection paul dupire out qui je le
rappelle est quelque chose d'unique en
europe est quelque chose de vraiment
exceptionnel
on travaille un grand slam en
l'occurrence didier racheter et ses
équipes
j'ai été testé positif ils m'ont appelé
dans la journée et je suis rentré à
l'hôpital
rachid d'un clavier ajoute le soir j'en
suis ressorti le vendredi après un début
de traitement donc j'ai pas me prononcer
sur le bien-fondé du traitement moi je
suis une passion que je fais lanta je
fais confiance aux médecins ce pas parce
que je suis parlementaire que j'ai un
avis sur la question je ne suis pas
médecin donc je fais confiance au
médecin qui m'a fait le test et qui m'a
prescrit ce traitement est un traitement
que j'ai choisi
c'est pas une carte un fromage dessert
avec laquelle il c'est pas comme ça que
ça s'est passé donc je j'ai confiance
dans les personnes qui m'ont suivi qui
monte piste et non prescrit ce
médicament
il n'empêche valérie boyer certains
patients dirai peut-être que vous avez
de la chance de pouvoir en bénéficier
parce que la communauté scientifique
restent partagés sur ce traitement l'
oms qui condamne l' usage de médicaments
sans preuve de leur efficacité
didier raoult cours vous explique
d'ailleurs il l'a expliqué ici même sur
notre antenne c'était le 27 février donc
ça date un peu que selon lui ce
traitement était efficace
pourquoi ça met autant de temps cela en
vous on peut tout simplement avoir la
nuit d'un simple citoyen sur ce sujet je
n'en fait rien tout ce que je sais c'est
que le traitement que je qui m'a été
prescrit n'est pas d'un traitement
expérimental puisque didier raoult et
que l'a expérimenté déjà enfin la met en
place déjà pour faire quelle maladie
notamment la literie peuvent donc y la
faune et des centaines et des centaines
de personnes avec ce traitement
vous savez que le spécialiste des
maladies intracellulaire ces
spécialistes mondiales et notamment de
cette maladie en ce qui concerne le coc
u19
effectivement il a jugé qu'il y avait
des similitudes et qu'il pouvait être
administrés à ses patients pour moi sur
le traitement j'ai pas à me prononcer je
ne suis pas compétente pour ça et
d'ailleurs je pense que c'est bien de
l'écouté des personnes compétentes et je
je je pense que didier raoult tous ces
partis des personnes extrêmement
compétente sur le sujet sinon il ne
serait pas le spécialiste mondial qu'il
est reconnu en revanche là où je peux
avoir un avis de citoyen et sur les
masques dont malheureusement donc ils
sont pas encore à disposition tous les
soignants de tous les policiers de
toutes les personnes qui vendent des
produits alimentaires de première
nécessité s'abstiendrait sujet et le
deuxième avis que je peux avoir en tant
que citoyenne et parlementaires et
d'ailleurs je vais demander au ministre
dans un courrier au gouvernement par
dans un courrier que nous avons adressé
avec julien aubert et d'autres
parlementaires fait que les tests de
dépistage famille à disposition du plus
grand nombre
qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
contrairement à ce qui se passe en
allemagne et ce qui fait passer dans un
autre grand pays la corée du sud
donc voilà les sujets sur lesquels je
peux me prononcer ce que je pense que
pour lutter contre une épidémie il faut
être expliquée aujourd'hui vous
expliquer comment justement qu'en france
ne fasse pas des tests systématiques qui
confinent effectivement les gens
voudraient me dire ça n'a rien à voir
mais si parce qu'encore et du sud
précisément il teste abondamment mais il
ne confine pas tout le monde et ils
suivent d'ailleurs les personnes malades
les malades et qui n'est pas valable qui
équipent contaminer l'autre et qui ne
peut pas contaminer l'autre et c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles d'ailleurs
la maladie fait moins répandu cochet
pareil pour l'allemagne en tout cas
d'après les informations que vos
confrères journalistes relatent donc ça
m'a fait un problème d'organisation et
d'un choix d'organisation le café le
gouvernement voilà et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je pense que le test
aujourd'hui il doit être mis à
disposition de façon plus importante
d'ailleurs je crois que ce sont des
mesures qui ont été été pris et quant au
traitement jusqu'à preuve du contraire
en tout cas d'après ce que la presse
relate c'est le seul traitement contre
pose aujourd'hui on au malade atteint du
clavier de 19 traitement qui a fait ses
preuves dans d'autres d'affection donc
moi je suis une patiente jeu j'ai
consulté un médecin en l'occurrence un
éminent spécialiste qui me pousse ce
traitement j'ai confiance dans son
jugement aujourd'hui plusieurs
informations notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux des assesseurs testés positifs
une semaine après le premier tour des
municipales ce qu'il ne fallait le
maintenir selon vous ce premier tour
écoutez c'est vraiment un sujet qui est
extrêmement difficile et c'est toujours
compliqué de donner la météo de la
veille au moment où le président de la
république a pris cette décision il
avait probablement j'ose imaginer un
certain nombre d'éléments et d'ailleurs
la décision a été prise de façon très
curieuse puisque il a dit je décide de
maintenir ce premier tour
municipal mais j'invite les personnes de
plus de 70 ans être pu tenter en fait en
quelque sorte à pas se déplacer et la
veille le premier ministre n'a pas
arrêté le scrutin mais il a dit aux
personnes fragiles de pas se rendre de
ne pas sortir et il a fait fermer les
restaurants le machin etc et il a dit
que l'adil écoles seraient fermées
donc c'est vrai que c'est très compliqué
afin d'assurer un scrutin dans sept
camps dans ces conditions nous nous
avons subi ces décisions est clairement
le scrutin n'a pas été sincère puisque
un bon nombre de personnes ne se sont
pas rendus aux orres aux urnes et on a
vu une chute de la participation
et quant aux personnes qui ont tenu les
bureaux de vote
eh bien elle n'avait rien pour se
protéger ou à part du gel
hydroalcoolique et à marseille je sais
que nous avions organisé de quoi nous
laver les mains alors c'est vrai que on
peut vraiment se poser la question de la
responsabilité de ces personnes qui sont
exposées à du public sans masque sans
protection et d'ailleurs le scrutin n'a
pas pu être maintenue puisque vous allez
que deuxième tour est reportée après le
confinement
donc effectivement ce une décision qui
est lourde de sens mais qui ne nous
appartient pas nous élus a fortiori de
l'opposition et c'est quelque chose qui
a été décidé par le gouvernement n'ont
mois dans députés en tant que candidate
sur des listes à marseille on ne va pas
demander mon avis voilà et je devais
assumer l'organisation du scrutin
merci beaucoup valérie boyer députée des
républicains des bouches de rhône on
vous laisse vous reposer bon
rétablissement vous mercier en tout cas
d'avoir été en direct